heeft emotie e geeft ruimte aan kritiek Israël
en als 1 Groot deel van Nederland dat niet doet
zie ik graag 1 groen lint
die ruimte geeft om op te staan tegen het zionisme
en het racisme
partijbestuur ontraat deze emotie
de indieners stellen zionisme
gelijk aan het streven naar 1 raszuiveren
joodse staat dat klopt niet
deze emotie
draagt niet bij aan de strijd voor onze ideale
uh zionisme
is gebaseerd op de racistische leugen
dat de veiligheid van joden
alleen verzekerd kan worden
we hebben van de zuiver witte etno staat sianisme
nee nee kom op
wat gebeurt hier
nou nee
ik HEB net aangegeven het belang van omgangsregels
en je weet het
als je dit zo zegt dat je dan mensen echt echt kwetst
ik Wil je nu vragen om het podium te verlaten
en ruimte te geven aan de volgende spreker
nou ja nou ik ik ik
ik vind het echt belachelijk
dat is duidelijk
is de hoogste tijd dat wij de rol van het zionisme in
alle openheid kunnen bedoelen
dankjewel deze emotie
ligt de nootzaak vast en verdient daarom massale steun
en het is zo ongekend typisch dat de
microfoon voor je neus wordt weggetrokken
het is zo typisch dat we hier
problematiseren
dat we racisme
in verband brengen met de zionistische ideologie
het kan echt niet
ja en precies daarom is deze emotie nodig
ik zie dat het je ongemakkelijk maakt
maar dat is precies waarom we het hier moeten hebben
dat is waar dat wacht even
dat is waarom
nee dat is waarom we het hier voor deze
emotie moeten hebben
stem alsjeblieft voor deze emotie dankjewel
oké ik Wil je vraag het podium te verlaten